women broke the monogamy contract first
women will go off all day about men not
being monogamous but
what we're only four percent of women
are saying that they're virgins on their
wedding day that's four percent so if
women are sleeping with multiple men
before marriage uh it's almost like a
catch-22 where they say well I can do
what I want before marriage but after
marriage when men have the most sexual
Capital because men you know Peak around
like 35 right even on some dating apps
say men peek at 50 or women Peak at 21.
so when women are at their sexual
Marketplace value at the highest like
when they have the most agency the most
power we don't pick marriage because we
keep pushing it off so it's almost like
a catch-22 where when women have the
most power we don't pick monogamy but
when men have the most power they're
expected to we're